I actually studied political science in  college I believe that every vote counts  I rely get something like I'm not a  cynical bastard  I definitely feel a little  responsibility to vote sometimes like my  idealism goes a lot further than what I  actually end up doing in reality  for a long time I didn't feel a civic  duty to vote because I thought ah I'm  not a swing state it doesn't really  matter but now especially with this  election seeing how much every vote  counts I definitely feel that I have a  civic duty to vote  well as powerful you know my ice is  melting and you know it's nice to see  the word that's so I think you know on  everyone's mind right now being carved  out of ice and see it melt away